[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres de ce mercredi 1er
juillet des dépistages avec vite 19 à
elancourt cette journée de tests s'est
déroulée aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la
grande campagne lancée en ile-de-france
par les ars et les citoyens étaient
nombreux sur le parvis de l'hôtel de
ville alors que l'union européenne
rouvre aujourd'hui ses frontières avec
quinze pays du monde les français
devraient une grande majorité privilégié
des vacances sur le sol national
qu en est il des réservations de séjours
pour cet été reportage dans des agences
de voyages à montigny le bretonneux et
versailles
et puis si vous ne partez pas vous
pourrez tout de même voyagé en juillet
au son des musiques de la méditerranée
de l'angleterre
trois concerts en plein air sont
proposés sur le site du musée national
de port royal des champs à magny les
hameaux
mais avant de développer ces titres une
école maternelle de mantes-la-jolie
fermé pour cause de coronavirus quatre
cas ont été décelés dans l'établissement
des anémones dans le quartier du val
fourré il s'agit de trois élèves et d'un
animateur qui intervient régulièrement
sur place
l agence régionale de santé a lancé une
procédure pour identifier et isoler les
cas contact pendant 14 jours l école ne
devrait rouvrir qu'à la rentrée de
septembre se faire tester justement à
lakovic 19 et le tout en 20 minutes
seulement c'est l'opération qui était
proposé gratuitement aujourd'hui à
elancourt par l' agence régionale de
santé
marylène iapichino nicolas landry et
hugo kitson éteindre la narine pour ce
tests virologiques qui détermine si vous
avez ou non le coronavirus au moment du
test une opération proposée par l'
agence régionale de santé d'île de
france
on est à la sixième opération dans les
yvelines on a deux types d'organisations
une comme aujourd'hui où en fait avec
les mairies on travaille à la logistique
l'installation des barnums et puis sont
les équipes de l'ap-hp qui viennent clés
en main
avec les équipes administratives les
équipes de préleveurs et un médecin
on a eu donc un coup de fil de la rs
nous demandons a effectivement si vous
voulez participer à cette campagne
cette campagne de dépistage et nous
avons répondu favorablement parce
qu'effectivement on pense que c'est
vraiment très important de faire cette
campagne pour éviter effectivement là
que l'épidémie recommence l'organisation
s'est faite en huit jours la
communication via les réseaux sociaux et
le bouche à oreille a bien fonctionné
plus de 400 personnes ont pris leur
ticket pour se faire dépister 500 tests
sont disponibles en tout c'est moins
bien que de manger une glace et c'est
pas mal obligés à un âge où j'ai quand
même le bon 55 ans on sait pas trop
comment ça malheureusement ça peut ça
peut finir je vais partir en vacances je
voudrais pas contaminer des amis donc
c'est pour cette raison je viens les
résultats sont délivrés entre 24 et 48
heures la rs a contacté les communes des
mureaux de guyancourt et de trappes pour
organiser de nouvelles opérations d'ici
le 10 juillet à elancourt huit personnes
sont décédées du coronavirus depuis le
début de l'épidémie dans l'actualité
aussi les changements au 1er juillet
hausse de certains prix du tabac nouveau
dispositif pour le chômage partiel
allocations chômage revalorisées
il est également possible depuis
aujourd'hui partout en france de payer
ses amendes impôts encore factures dans
un bureau de tabac
ce paiement de proximité qui peut se
faire en espèces ou carte bancaire
jusqu'à 300 euros était expérimenté dans
les yvelines depuis février dernier et
les factures concernés peuvent être pour
la cantine scolaire l'hôpital la crèche
ou encore la piscine le document doit
contenir un qr code est les vacances
scolaires débutent à la fin de la
semaine des congés forcément dans un
contexte particulier avec cette crise
sanitaire
beaucoup de français se posent la
question de la destination en france en
europe voire dans le monde puisque
depuis aujourd'hui les frontières
européennes sont ouvertes à nouveau pour
quinze pays où les yvelinois vont-ils
partir éléments de réponse avec mathilde
et demi et mélanie poker
sur lui de veste oui c'est possible
cette saint-quentinoise programme ses
prochaines vacances
un voyage plus tôt en octobre mais
surtout s'en sortir de l'europe
on voyage pas mal surtout mon mari mais
je connais pas budapest est ce un rêve
d'y aller depuis très longtemps
c'est un projet qu'on a depuis depuis
deux ans et on aimerait bien bien le
faire dans cette agence à nîmes antennes
les demandes ont été réduites
emmanuel van un voyage par jour à la
même époque l'année dernière deux à
trois séjours étaient réservées
quotidiennement et pour l'été la
tendance va plutôt à l'hexagone
beaucoup nous disent ben je veux pas
partir en dehors de la france parce que
si jamais on doit être confiné
on veut pas être confinée à la
destination est d'autant plus d'avoir à
payer les frais que ça engendre être
resté bloqué dans un pays étranger où le
vent me
ma vie pour l'instant peut pas y aller
un voyage hors d'europe encore
compliquer dès le 1er juillet les
français peuvent se déplacer en dehors
de l'union européenne à condition que
l'épidémie soit maîtrisé dans le pays
souhaitait pour cette agence
versaillaise 150 voyages ont été annulés
depuis le confinement
même là des gens qui devaient partir le
3 juillet jean d'avoir une annulation de
vol pour la guadeloupe donc vraiment on
n'a aucune certitude et c'est ça qui est
le plus on va dire le plus compliqué ce
qu'on ne peut pas les rassurer qu'ils
sont ça se comprend qu'ils sont ils ont
envie de partir mais nous on n'a pas pu
sa passion selon les entreprises du
voyage cette année 87 % des français
projette de partir en vacances en france
et 13% à l'étranger lors des années
précédentes ils étaient plus de 30% à
quitter l'hexagone
la crise du coronavirus n'en finit pas
de faire des dégâts sur son passage en
raison des conséquences économiques 5000
postes vont être supprimés chez airbus
en france quinze mille
au niveau mondial le géant de
l'aéronautique l'a annoncé hier mardi
elle la confirmation devrait être donnée
cette semaine mais ce plan social ne
devrait pas concerner airbus défense n
space implantait elancourt un site est
de 2200 salariés à la division en
revanche étaient déjà concernés dès mars
par un plan de restructuration qui
prévoyait la suppression est de 99
postes à elancourt les syndicats avaient
défilé dans la zone d'activités de la
clé saint pierre en signe de
protestation dans le secteur du bâtiment
la reprise d'activité se fait
progressivement c'est dans ce contexte
que le centre de formation aux métiers
du btp attrape à organiser courant juin
plusieurs journées de rencontres entre
les futurs apprentis et les entreprises
l objectif permettre aux jeunes en
formation à la rentrée 2020 de trouver
un employeur pour leur alternance et
nicolas landry et michael et demi
d'euros
de travaux on va dire les 50% sur chance
50%
sur les bases 10 avec la reprise
d'activité sur les chantiers le besoin
en main d'oeuvre se fait ressentir les
entreprises se focalisent de leur
recrutement notamment sur les apprentis
c'est le cas de ce grand groupe
une quinzaine de postes en apprentissage
est proposée tous nos chantiers ont été
arrêtés du coup beaucoup de retard sur
certains lots chantier donc on a besoin
de main d'oeuvre et nous chez vinci on a
une force politique jeunes aussi donc
tous les ans contexte particulier ou pas
on a besoin on recrute beaucoup
d'apprentis pour cette pme spécialisée
dans les canalisations l'assainissement
et l'eau potable échantillons été
reportée pendant le confinement
les recrutements sont nécessaires pour
sa reprise d'activité on a un manque de
main d'oeuvre aujourd'hui et pour le
futur proche avec des chefs de chantier
ou une manoeuvre vieillissante donc il
faut former aujourd'hui pour garder une
dynamique et conserver à voir des jeunes
pour demain l'impact des faits kévin
c'est que ça a retardé
nos chantiers de deux mois mais
aujourd'hui ce soit sur le volume il n'y
a pas eu de baisse ni d'augmentation
sont à 100 c ap bts et bac professionnel
toutes les filières du centre de
formation des métiers du btp à trappes
sont en apprentissage malgré la crise
sanitaire la structure a organisé cette
journée
objectif faciliter les rencontres entre
les entreprises et les jeunes dans le
domaine des travaux publics la demande
est forte
on a des demandes des grands groupes des
multinationales dont des agents sont
implantés dans les yvelines
et on a aussi une demande importante
des entreprises
type pme ou des entreprises artisanales
on a beaucoup craint il ya quelques mois
que les
que les demandes soient soit très limité
les grâces aussi peut-être aux aides à
l'apprentissage et puis à la confiance
que des entreprises accordent aux jeunes
la demande reste forte donc on est on
est confiant la recherche d'une
entreprise pour une formation en
apprentissage parfois un véritable
parcours du combattant
un sentiment renforcé par le contexte
actuel même sens le vide
c'est toujours compliqué de trouver une
entreprise tourne alternance c'est assez
long même si on s'y prend assez tôt on a
toujours des réponses assez lente par
rapport aussi à ce qui s'est passé au co
vide s'est tue c'est plus difficile
d'avoir des entretiens cesser les
entretiens qu'ont fait par audiovisuel
et parfois ça n'aboutit pas vraiment
pendant la période de ducobu
on n'a pas pu se déplacer n'a pas pu
postuler et ont ensuite à les joindre
près de deux cent cinq jeunes sont
formés chaque année en apprentissage au
centre de formation des métiers du btp
attrape 40 demandeurs d'emploi habitants
de saint quentin en yvelines former au
métier de développeur web cette
initiative s'inscrit dans le
développement du campus numérique par
l'agglomération
elle est financée en partie par le fonds
social européen est la formation de
trois mois sera dispensée par l'école
o'clock en télé présentiel plusieurs
compétences seront enseignées
l'apprentissage et de la programmation
informatique la maîtrise des techniques
du développement et la conception d'un
site web les propos recueillis par
nicolas landry
maintenant on travaille en partenariat
avec la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour mener des
campagnes de sensibilisation
d'information et de formation spécifique
spécifique au territoire et former des
personnes au métier de développeur web
notre particularité c'est de travailler
à la fois sur les personnes qui sont en
demande d'emploi
ça représente à peu près 70 % de nos
publics et aussi les salariés en
reconversion
on a des personnes qui ont enfin une
forme des personnes qui ont en moyenne
entre 30 et 35 ans d'habitude mais on a
toutes les tranches d'âge de 16 à 55 ans
cet acteur du web est basée à montigny
le bretonneux l'afnic l'association
française pour le nommage internet en
coopération lance un cycle de
conférences la thématique les abus sur
internet
une série de quatre tables rondes
organisées jusqu'au 19 novembre pour
sensibiliser le public autour de ce
sujet le premier événement en ligne va
aborder la question du traitement des
abus dans le contexte de la crise
qu'ovide 19è les détails dans cet
entretien mené par nicolas landry en
compagnie de pierre bonny ce bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur général
de l'afnic alors l'afrique c'est
l'association française pour le nommage
internet en coopération vous est
implantée à saint quentin en yvelines et
vous êtes notamment gestionnaire
historique du point fr des sites
internet
alors avant de revenir sur l'événement
le forum afnic pour un internet de
confiance que vous organisez du 2
juillet au 19 novembre
pouvez vous nous expliquer en quoi
consistaient l'activité de gestion du
point fr bonjour à tous alors l'activité
de gestion du point fr ça consiste d'une
part à permettre l'enregistrement de
noms de domaine en point fr à travers
des bureaux d'enregistrement qui sont
des hébergeurs internet la plupart du
temps et puis ça permet aussi ça
consiste à faire fonctionner le point fr
c'est à dire à faire en sorte que quand
vous avez créé un site web qui
fonctionne en point fr les internautes
puissent y accéder
donc au fait on est à la fois une sorte
de notaire de l'internet ont dit à qui
appartient les noms de domaine et mais
aussi un aiguilleur c'est à dire qu'on
permet de diriger tous les internautes
vers vos sites
c'est alors si vous avez un rôle
d'information de sensibilisation et
c'est dans ce cadre là que vous
organisez à partir du 2 juillet et
jusqu'au 19 novembre
un cycle de débats sous le nom du forum
afnic pour un internet de confiance et
les thématiques de ces débats c'est de
lutter contre les abus en ligne alors
pourquoi avoir choisi cette thématique
alors vous avez merci d'avoir rappelé
que l'afrique au delà de son rôle de
gestionnaire du point fr elle l'a aussi
un rôle historiquement en tant
qu'association die passion d'un certain
nombre de débats au sein de la
communauté internet française nous a
semblé que cette question des abus
étaient étaient traités de manière un
peu disparate
aujourd'hui faisait l'objet d'un certain
nombre de prises de position qui parfois
été techniquement assez mal informés et
une assemblée que justement ce caractère
un peu neutre du registre internet.fr
pouvait permettre de rassembler un
certain nombre de docteurs pour faire le
point sur ce qu'est un abus comment on
peut s'en prémunir et quels sont les
moyens techniques de gérer les abus
sachant que nous sommes à l'afnic assez
assez prudent sur le fait que les abus
sur internet que techniquement
parfois ça se règle par d'autres
manières donc c'est une manière de faire
le point et aussi peut-être d'éclairer à
travers ce point là des décideurs qui
peuvent être des législateurs sur les
meilleurs moyens de limiter les abus et
les risques sur internet
alors pour nos téléspectateurs est-ce
que vous avez des exemples d'abus sur
internet alors les exemples les plus
courants ce sont des exemples qui sont
liées par exemple à des arnaques des ce
qu'on appelle le phishing c'est à dire
des d'aider des personnes mal
intentionnées qui se font passer pour un
site internet parce qu'ils ne sont pas
pour récupérer des données des données
cartes bancaires des données
personnelles des choses de ce type là
vous avez aussi des abus qui relève de
l'usurpation d'identité on se fait
passer à travers un email pour quelqu'un
d'autre pour commander des choses à sa
place c'est donc il ya finalement toute
une série d'abus possibles
et puis il ya des abus qui sont des abus
abu techniques par exemple le spam
c'est un abus technique c'est à dire que
non seulement ça pose des problèmes à
ceux qui le reçoivent
mais ça pose aussi des problèmes aux
infrastructures de l'internet parce que
c'est énormément de messages qui partent
alors qu'ils ne sont pas légitimes
donc ça sera probablement un élément
dans les mois à venir qu'on aura
distinguer quels sont les abus classique
et les abus technique le premier sujet
que vous allez aborder ce jeudi 2
juillet de 10h à 12h c'est une
conférence en ligne pour eux public pour
tout le monde c'est le traitement des
abus dans le contexte de la crise
sanitaire que nous venons de traverser
y at il des abus spécifique à cette
crise
alors ça sera l'objet du débat d'où je
ne veux pas à présenter ce que diront
nos invités puisque nous ne sommes pas
les seuls à parler en bien sûr il y aura
la direction générale de la concurrence
et de la répression des fraudes y aura
un homologues étrangers notre homologue
danois et il y aura un grand bureau
d'enregistrement qui est gandhi qui
s'exprimeront là dessus néanmoins nous
la vision qu'on a c'est que ya pas eu
d'abus particulièrement spécifique
durant cette crise il ya eu les mêmes
adultes d'habitude
simplement on était plus attentifs et
ont considéré que ces abus étaient
peut-être plus dangereux qu'il ne
l'était d'habitude c'est à dire que des
arnaques pour enfin des sites en ligne
qui vous envoie jamais votre votre
commande
malheureusement ça existe mais ça existe
des sites en ligne qui vous envoie
jamais le gel hydroalcoolique pendant la
crise a beaucoup plus énervés les jambes
d'habitude
voilà donc qui a ri il ya eu le gérer
une mobilisation contre les abus en
ligne qui a été plus forte en raison au
fond de deux ans sanitaire et du
confinement et du fait que beaucoup de
gens se sont reportés sur les achats en
ligne parce que précisément ils
pouvaient pas acheter
en vrai dans la rue dans les boutiques
dont pavot abus mais une sensibilité
beaucoup plus forte aux abus je dirais
habituelle et pour en savoir plus le
plus du coût par rapport à cette
thématique
il faudra participer en tout cas en
ligne se connecter sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran c'est ce
jeudi 2 juillet de 10h à 12h merci
pierre bonny merci beaucoup à vous
directeur général de l'afnic
au chapitre culturel les trois prochains
samedis seront musicaux à magny les
hameaux le musée national de port royal
des champs et le théâtre national de
saint quentin en yvelines se sont
associés pour proposer trois concerts en
plein air une invitation au voyage entre
les rives de la méditerranée de
l'angleterre présentation avec aurélie
oms
[Musique]
la voix de la soprano algérienne amel
brahim djelloul résonnera le 4 juillet
prochain sur le site du musée national
de port royal des champs à magny les
hameaux
après la période d'arrêt culturel due à
la crise sanitaire le musée le théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines souhaité
remettre les artistes sur le devant de
la scène
on s'était dit que c'était l'occasion
d'aller sur des labels ras des musiques
croisés ou des musiques plurielles comme
on veut et de voyager entre les les
rites la méditerranée jusqu'à
l'angleterre et puis revenir en espagne
essayé de traverser à la fois les styles
et les époques
après les mélodies orientales cap le
samedi 11 juillet sur l'angleterre du
xviie siècle avec la musique baroque
d'henry purcell
[Musique]
le 18 juillet sera consacré aux musiques
du siècle d'or espagnol
trois concerts trois univers musicaux
différents voulue par le directeur
artistique de ces manifestations
jérôme correas directeur musical de
l'ensemble les paladins le public de
saint quentin les connaît bien cet
ensemble puisqu'on l'a cueilli à
plusieurs reprises très souvent sur de
la musique baroque ski sa spécialité
dont il connaît bien le territoire il
connaît bien par royal aussi dans que le
contact avec qui plus est avec le musée
national a été extrêmement simple c'est
pour ça qu'on a été plutôt très réactif
on savait ce qu'on pouvait faire
tout le monde se connaissait toutes les
forces en présence se connaissaient à
chaque rendez vous une heure de voyage
musical en plein air tout en respectant
les gestes barrière port du masque
obligatoire tout comme la réservation
[Musique]
depuis la semaine dernière votre
rubrique hebdomadaire dans les salles
est de retour dans le journal chaque
semaine visite dans les cinémas des
environs pour connaître leur
programmation
ce soir c'est au ciné cette d'elancourt
que nous nous rendons et c'est au micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude
alors après cette date de cette longue
période de confinement nous sommes très
heureux évidemment de vous retrouver au
ciné 7 et notamment avec le coup de
coeur du ciné cette semaine une sortie
nationale
c'est un petit peu difficile en ce
moment parce que les distributeurs sont
relativement frileux mais on est très
content de sortir le second film 2
grégory magne
le réalisateur qui avait précédemment
réalisé le film l'air de rien avec
michel delpech qui racontait les affres
d'un chanteur un peu esseulé et oublié
et cette fois ci le film s'appelle les
parfums il est interprétée par
emmanuelle devos que tout le monde
connaît qu'un habile au moca récemment
avec isabelle huppert et un autre acteur
qui s'appelle
grégory vont-elles voilà qui avait déjà
joué dans l'air de rien donc les parfums
c'est l'histoire d'une parfumeuse enfin
de quelqu'un qui crée des fragrances qui
est quelqu'un de un petit peu hautain
supérieur qui vit isolé dans son monde
elle est très connue très réputé et elle
va recruter un jour un chauffeur qui ne
va pas avoir peur de s'opposer à elle et
il va se tisser forcément des liens
relativement intéressant entre les deux
le servage pas un seul instant vous avez
levé la tête pour la regarder mais jean
pas qu'une odeur si vous n'êtes même pas
capable d'élire deux mots juste deux
mots merci inscrit
voilà c'est l'histoire de ce film que
vous pourrez découvrir cette semaine sur
nos écrans au ciné c'est très ouvert
d'elancourt avant de vous laisser il
sera peut être désigné ce soir comme le
village préféré des français montfort
l'amaury 3000 habitants représente l'île
de france dans l'émission de france 3
animée par stéphane bern
une compétition rude face à treize
autres candidats dans toute la france
montfort l'amaury pour en tout cas
compter sur ses atouts la tour anne de
bretagne qui domine la commune son
église saint pierre et son cimetière
aussi avec son cloître vieux de 500 ans
c'est là que repose l'illustrent charles
aznavour pour suivre l'émission trois
écrans géants seront disposés ce soir
dans le village c'est à partir de 21h05
bonne chance aux montfortois voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]